it's Monday July fourteenth and this is
gamespot news I'm Chris water standing
in for Jess McDonald who's been stricken
ill buy some poisonous animal venomous
plant or noxious mineral no I will never
tire of making Australia jokes but yes I
will get on with the news a flurry of
fighting game news came out of Las Vegas
this weekend as evo 2014 played host to
a bunch of intense tournaments and a ton
of enthusiastic fans first up tekken 7
was leaked and then properly announced
by bandai namco it's being developed on
the Unreal Engine 4 and headed up by
series director cut suehiro hirata the
second bit of news was that Thunder God
and hat enthusiast ridin will be
playable in Mortal Kombat ten and
thirdly a trio of characters were
confirmed for the upcoming Super Smash
Brothers games for the wii u and 3ds
from Fire Emblem awakening come Robin
the default player character in both
male and female versions as well as
lucena the badass warrior from the
future who bears a striking resemblance
to spoiler redacted and finally
everyone's favorite reminder that f0 was
once a thing Captain Falcon vokoun
transition xbox one owners may soon have
a new way to give Microsoft their money
as soon as possible in a developer
produced video about sunset overdrive
insomniac games community manager
Brendan winfrey said that you will soon
be able to digitally pre-order games on
the Xbox one a feature that Microsoft's
head of Xbox Phil Spencer said last
month was still on the road map for
future updates Sony meanwhile introduced
pre-loading last month and speaking of
Sony remember that shiny white
PlayStation 4 that they revealed at e3
it'll be available as a bundle with
destiny when the game comes out on sep
tember 9th but Sony Computer
Entertainment president of worldwide
studios Shuhei Yoshida confirmed that
they will also sell it standalone later
this year in Europe no word yet on when
it will come to other territories let's
round things out with some cosplay news
because who doesn't like cosplay
cold-hearted trolls that's that's who in
the upcoming 3ds games Pokemon alpha
sapphire and Omega Ruby which are HD
remakes of Ruby
in sapphire there's going to be some
sweet pikachu cosplay no not like people
dressing up like Pikachu but Pikachu
dressing up like people well anime
people adorable and check out these
cosplayers poking fun at that hole III
brouhaha that came up when the
Assassin's Creed unity developer
explained that female assassins were
left out of the game because of all the
extra work it would take to include them
adorable there you have it folks a nice
little helping of news to get your week
started off right I may see you tomorrow
if Jess doesn't claw her way back to the
land of the living but she is tenacious
so who knows wish her well and discuss
the news in the comments below and I'll
see you next time